So let's recap the code we have at the end
of unit two. So we defined a procedure, get_next_target, that
would take a page, search for the first linked target
on that page, return that as the value of URL.
That would be the first output, and also return the
position where the end of the quote is so we
know how to continue. And then we define the procedure
print all_links that keeps going as long as we can.
As long as there are more URLs on the page. It
will find the next target. Store these in the variables URL and
endpos to keep track of the location end of string. If
there is a URL, what we did was just print it out
and then we update with the page to keep going. What
we want to do to change this is instead of just printing out
each URL as we find it, we want to collect the URLs. We
want to have a way to use the URLs so we can use
them to keep crawling to find new
pages. The structure we've been learning about this
unit is the way to do that. What we want to do is keep all the
URLs in a list. At the end of this procedure, instead of printing the links
as we go, we want to have a list of all the links that we found.
So this is what the current print_all_links procedure does.
It takes the page as its input and its output
is nothing. It doesn't return anything. All it does
is do some work, prints out all these links. But
we can't actually use them at the end, because
it doesn't return anything. So what we want to do is
change this. Instead of print_all_links, what we want is to
get_all_links. We want to actually have the links in a way
that we can use them. So what we want,
instead of printing all links is to actually get the
links. So we'll change the name of our procedure
to get_all_links. And instead of outputting none, what we want to
do is output a list of links. And that
should be the list that corresponds to the things that
we were printing before, but now instead of just
printing them, we want to output them as a list.